welcome back to las vegas now so
valentine's day doesn't have to be all
about chocolate and flowers instead you
can make it a party celebration at the
encore beach club and you can start the
celebrations early at the valentine's
themes foray you don't owe me here to
tell us more is david hadden from encore
beach club david thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me so we
were talking about this before as the
interview started this is going to be
the third year you guys are doing it so
tell us all about it and what people can
expect when they come to encore beach
club so you don't own me it's actually
so it's our valentine's themed event
and it's an encore beach club wednesday
february 9th
you can expect to see
some awesome photo activations there'll
be a champagne tower we're gonna have dj
five performing there's a lot of
exciting elements that go into this
night that make it uh one of our great
nights of the year yeah we're seeing
some video here look how fun that looks
i know i want to be like in that part of
that and let's just talk about the
how the night works and where people can
get tickets and all that fun stuff um so
you can get tickets on winsocial.com um
you can also um inquire about table
reservations and see a calendar of all
of our events for the year there oh yeah
you guys always have a lot going on but
this one sounds really fun and i have to
say champagne is my go-to drink so let's
talk about the partners and you know
what will the drinks be flowing that
night it's going to be great yeah so we
partnered with moet for this party uh so
it's going to be endless champagne
you're speaking my language baby let me
tell you and let's say you want to get
the party started a little bit earlier
in the night maybe go out with your
girlfriends have a good dinner where do
you suggest people you know go and find
dime before coming to the party it's
definitely going to be a casa playa and
cosplayers are new mexican restaurants
out of the wind
with a nightlife twist uh there's live
music with the dj in the lounge uh we're
gonna have valentine's themed cocktails
and desserts as well on this night so
that's gonna be really fun that's
awesome and i've heard great things
about coffee supplies so you can make a
whole night out of it and i i gotta ask
so you're doing this party before
valentine's day so should you grab your
girlfriends and make this like a
valentine's day or maybe if you just
aren't the biggest fan of valentine's
day this is the perfect way to celebrate
i think this party's uh really for
everybody
i like that well cheers to that
give us the information again so
everyone knows where to go tickets on
winsocial.com and table reservations and
for all the calendar events uh you can
go to winssocial.com awesome well thank
you so much that's where the party's at
you don't own me i love the name
all right rocky i'll send it over to you
thank you